let's go to Ryan from DC Ryan from DC
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey David uh great to talk to you again
I've spoke with you a couple of times so
I appreciate is my audio okay welcome
yeah your audio is fine
all right perfect
um I wanted to just ask you a policy
related question but around AI I mean I
know there's been a lot of news coming
out in the last two to three months with
Chet GPT and some of the uh language
learning models that are now coming out
for companies to use in kind of a
proprietary way with their own in-house
data and I I was looking at some
interviews I know the open AI CEO just
recently had a big interview with with
CNBC and um my question is really around
the economy and job replacement okay
um you know I it seems that uh chat gpt4
just recently released and you know the
Improvement of AI is not linear it is
exponential and it seems like our the
guard rails from a policy perspective
are just not only are they not there but
knowing that the pace in which our
government typically operates is not at
all exponential and so I have a concern
a around
the economy taking a significant hit and
just this being such disruptive
technology I'm wondering how do we kind
of galvanize
legislators especially legislators that
are not technically inclined to really
kind of listen to some of the the
thought leaders in the technology space
that we need to get these guardrails in
place do you think that that is a topic
that could be relevant in the upcoming
election cycle it seems that I mean I
work in the technology space so I might
be a little bit a little bit more
focused on some of the upcoming changes
but I guess from what I've seen you know
just from what I've seen I mean this is
incredibly disruptive technology and
could easily you know replace large
swaths of the white collar Workforce for
sure so here's the deal first of all on
the potential to replace large swaths of
the workforce I there are two views on
this I'll tell you what they are and
then I'll kind of give you my take one
view is I think closer to what you're
suggesting which is that this technology
is so disruptive that it is going to be
unlike anything in the past in its job
destroying potential it is going to
eliminate entire areas of work and
replace it with technology and lead to
technological unemployment potentially
irreversibly that's one view on the
other side there's the view that says
you know every time in history that
something like this has come along when
there started to be cars and people said
what's going to happen with all the
horse buggy drivers they'll have nothing
to do well the car industry brought with
it the need for mechanics and more
chauffeurs and all these different new
industries were created delivery
services
Etc the technology eliminated some jobs
but it created more okay so those are
the two extremes now the difference may
be
and there are some technologists who say
this is the case that where we are now
these are now destructive Technologies
from the point of view of employment
that something like chat GPT it's not
going to create more jobs than it
destroys that's what some people say
it's not obvious to me I don't I don't
have an answer to this yet because it is
absolutely the case that there are tons
of things including in customer service
and research and and things that if chat
GPT and those Technologies get better
they still spit out wrong information
regularly right now but if they get
better it's true there are lots of jobs
that would be destroyed but
for people who know how to use these
tools to draw new connections between
things and and and generate new ideas
there are still there's still the
possibility that they will actually
create new jobs in Industries as we
haven't even thought of yet so I I just
don't think I'm in a position yet to say
whether it will be the destructive force
some fear it will be or whether it will
be a great thing or it will be more like
Neil Postman says which is there will be
good and there will be bad and it will
come down to how it's regulated
yeah I I completely agree and those are
definitely the two schools of thought I
think a lot of the concern at least in
the technology space is especially the
the difference in the the distinguishing
factor between the kind of AI Revolution
and things like the Industrial
Revolution that created net new jobs is
that the pace of improvement with AI is
exponential in such a exponential way
that is unlike any other technological
Revolution we've experienced in all of
human history yeah that's the argument
that summer making like I outlined yeah
yeah so anyway I just was thinking about
that I'm wondering if you know from a
policy perspective you know uh if we do
start to see some employment getting
replaced if that will be
um a relevant topic for politicians in
the upcoming Cycles I think it should be
I think it should be but I don't know
that it will be
got it hey David thanks again for taking
my call Great to speak with you all
right there is Ryan from DC very very
very very important topic and eventually
it's going to be a huge issue